I makes me very soon we'll be happy
about your enemies Thanks can everyone
hear me okay okay okay this is joint
work with some people from University of
Pennsylvania so that the basic setting
is pretty simple where we have an
analyst on the left and we have a
database full of private data and this
analyst wants to answer a bunch of
queries on this data however this
database is private so he wants to make
sure that the answers that he gets don't
reveal too much about any individual no
database okay so I privacy I mean of
course differential privacy which we
heard a lot about today already so this
is kind of the sketch of what your
Venture privacy is we have a randomized
algorithm in the middle and it takes in
a databases input and has some output
range so the privacy guarantee should be
that if we change a single record and
input then kind of the distribution
outputs should be nearly the same okay
so once again here's the formal
definition which I'm not going to go
through it's a beautiful property it's
like we've already heard about so
jumping to our problem we we study a
very well-known problem which is the
query release problem so we suppose that
we have a space of possible records we
call its X and for now we'll think there
are just D binary attributes so each
individual's record is a bit string of
length D our database will be a
collection of n of these records we can
represent as kind of like a histogram
and endless want an accurate answers to
a large collection of queries we're
going to call this collection crazed
queue and these queries will be counting
queries so these are crazed of the form
what fraction of the database satisfies
some property P or say P is say people
above 50 or something like that so our
goal will be to privately construct kind
of an approximate database t hat which
will approximate D and then use this
approximate database D hat to answer
these queries okay so there are many
approaches to solving this problem I'm
going to focus in this talk on
approaches from learning theory but
there are many other approaches
so two algorithms that I want to focus
on r1 by to work rough button button
which they give query released via
boosting and a different algorithm via a
heart and rockland who give a
multiplicative weights based algorithm
for releasing answers these queries so
this second algorithm has been evaluated
experimentally bar hardly getting cherry
and it performs pretty well when a
number of binary attributes is not too
big so what is the bottleneck well the
second algorithm algorithm operates on
distributions over all the possible
records so we can see that when the
number of attributes gets a little too
big say for number of attributes is
bigger than 100 the number of records
gets really enormous so for more than
100 attributes with something like 10 to
the 30 records and this becomes quickly
intractable okay so the question is is
it possible to do better kind of
adapting these algorithms to do to get
around this bottleneck unfortunately in
general that the answer is no there's a
collection of very nice impossibility
results showing that on this
exponentially large collection of
queries we cannot hope to answer it
accurately and efficiently in general so
that's kind of disappointing so are our
work can be seen as kind of
reconfiguring some of these existing
algorithms in order to isolate this hard
step and this hard set we want to kind
of pull it out of the algorithms so that
we can apply existing constraint solving
technology on this problem I mean this
this hard step is really theoretically
hard but there's been lots of solvers
that I've been developed to kind of
solve these problems pretty well in
practice so we can see how well we might
hope to perform okay so today brief
outline and first going to talk about
the query release as a zero-sum game to
kind of give some motivation of what our
algorithm is doing next I'm going to
talk about what the equilibrium of this
game is and what that might mean for
query release I'll give our query
release algorithm third and finally I
talk quickly about some really really
preliminary performance numbers okay so
to define the query this game will first
define these two players we have a data
player and a query player the data
player's actions corresponding to
records
possible records and the query player's
actions correspond to queries in this
class q that we want to answer okay so
to define the payoffs for suppose that
one player plays are and other player
plays cue this will be the payoff this
quantity q of our MySQL D and the data
players trying to minimize this quantity
and the query player tries that
maximizes quantity so it's a zero sum
game so this might seem pretty
complicated but for some intuition we
could think about the data pairs actions
is kind of database with a single record
so the record r is just can be thought
of as a database with just the record
are the query player q is intuitively
kind of trying to play queries with high
error and this payoff here kind of is
the error because here D is the true
database so this is kind of the error of
the approximation are on this query q
compare the true database so a down
players client and some sense to find a
good database that approximates the true
database now it's a very natural idea to
kind of look at what happens at the new
equilibrium of this game so for us to
kind of define what equilibrium means
i'll just say that the data player has a
distribution d hat and over the records
and query player has a distribution Q
hat over the Krays we'll say we're kind
of at an approximate libram if neither
player can gain more than alpha by
playing another distribution so what
does this mean for query release we know
that there's kind of a true database
like a perfect database so this data
player is playing this true database he
expects zero loss or zero pay off
because the error on any query is going
to be zero an expectation so we can say
is that if we're kind of at this an
approximate equilibrium the the data
pairs strategy you must kind of answer
all the queries in queue with error at
most alpha and this is very good because
this is exactly what we want for queer
movies so our goal will be to kind of
compute this equilibrium in a private
way so I don't really want to get into
too many details of how we actually do
this I'll just sketch on a very high
level kind of two approaches to come to
constructing this equilibrium the primal
approach we kind of manipulate a
candidate database over all the records
X
this is a very well studied idea and the
optimization problem will be to find a
query in queue with high error kind of a
dual approach which is kind of playing
the same game but from a different point
of view we're going to manipulate a
distribution over queries q and we're
going to try to find a record in the
possible record space with low error on
this distribution over queries and this
is also a very well-studied approach
kind of qualitatively we want to think
about this distribution over records as
being this is kind of very big
distribution the space of possible
records is very large so this problem
like maintaining this or manipulating
this this candidate database is very
expensive as intractable this
optimization problem on the other hand
we like to think about the query class
as being big but not exponentially big
so we'll be happy running in times a
linear in the number of queries so in
that sense we think of this optimization
problem is small and being somewhat
tractable there's still approach it's
kind of the flipped around version so we
have the distribution now to manipulate
it is is relatively easy because there's
not that many queries so this is a small
intractable thing however this
optimization problem becomes hard
because there's a large space of
possible records and we kind of want to
search through the records to find a
record with low error so we kind of
squished around the two points of view
so I want to focus on this step here
this optimization problem here to see
like how really how intractable is it
and what exactly is going on yep yes yes
that's right okay okay so let's take a
closer look at the dual optimization
problem so the main task is we will we
will sample queries from our query
distribution call the q1 through us and
we need to do this for privacy which I'm
not going to talk about too much well
let's just say that we're given these
queries q 1 through us and what we want
to do now is want us to find a record
that minimizes the average error over
these queries so that's just this
quantity here you can see that each term
here is kind of the error see this error
on chronique us of our
however we note that kind of this
database d here is fixed it's not really
part of the optimization so we can this
is really equipment to solving this
problem now and this problem we'll see
is just really a pure optimization
problem so in like the particular form
might depend on what these queries are
but this is just a really standard
optimization problem there are no
privacy concerns at all here anymore so
we're free to use whatever constraint
solving technology we want to solve this
problem okay so just some some theorems
are dual query alguns the satisfied
differential privacy also it has an
accuracy guarantee so with high
probability will answer all the queries
with error alpha alpha it's like this
quantity I want to stress that this
error is not state-of-the-art there's
better algorithms that have better known
guarantees however the strength of our
approach is that we've kind of factor
door algorithm in a different way so
that we can apply different tools to see
whether we can get a better performance
in practice but this this result is nice
but it's not really the best known
proficiency like I said optimization
problem depends on the specific kind of
query and unfortunately this step is
often hard so often empty hard so so how
do we actually gain if this optimization
is hard it seems like we've kind of
traded one problem for another problem
because we still have this hard step so
one big gain is that we manage a smaller
distribution so we kind of maintain that
distribution over queries rather than
records so we we do save if the number
of queries say is smaller the number of
possible records which we kind of assume
is the typical case also this
optimization doesn't involve privacy so
we can use any any standard solver and
people have developed very good solvers
for these kinds of problems and we can
also try to use further heuristics so
for these kinds of optimizations we kind
of give up on the guaranteed accuracy we
still guarantee privacy but we can see
how well we can perform if we say if the
optimization problem is too hard and the
solver takes too long we'll just cut it
off and take the best solution we found
in the first a minute we all strive
running for a few rounds or in playing
with other parameters but at always we
always guarantee that the
see is it is good so does it perform
well I just can describe some
preliminary results so our databases
binary attributes like I said we tested
this on randomly generated data as well
as real data and the queries that we try
to answer these so-called three-way
marginal queries so these are queries of
the form what fraction the database
satisfies a B and C where you can think
of a B and C as three attributes so the
optimization problem for this class of
queries is related to max 3 set it's not
exactly the same as Max three-sided bits
it's a variant so we solved this by
encoding this problem as an integer
program and feeding into cplex which is
a very optimized integer program solver
and we take the best solution found in
the first 60 seconds which we've
experimental verified to usually be
pretty good often we found that cplex
finds a very good solution very quickly
but it takes a very very long time to
prove that it is really the best
solution but heuristic alee seems to
work pretty well and the hardware is
nothing too special this is kind of just
like a medium performance desktop
computer so in principle you could run
this on your laptop and it should get
similar numbers so here are some
performance numbers this is for a real
networking data with about 100
independent binary attributes this is
some kind of packet data it's 500,000
records and 500,000 queries so we find
that most the time we actually spend is
not on the optimization step but it's
actually under state value in the
queries so this kind of suggests that if
we if we could work more on a valley
evaluating these queries faster we might
Billy gain even better performance but
the performance is already not so bad so
on the Left plot here I'm plotting the
average error which is an additive error
versus epsilon which is the privacy
guarantee i should note that the average
are not like trivial error is is one
because all of our queries answers are
between 0 and 1 so if you have error
error one then that's really not useful
but our average error is well below one
all these cases we can also plot on the
run time in minutes and we
again answer all of these queries in say
roughly an hour so there's a dependence
on epsilon because when epsilon gets
bigger we can run for more steps and it
takes longer for algorithm to go but
still seems fairly reasonable here's
some experiments on randomly biased data
so this is has a lot more attributes
with 2,000 independent binary attributes
a hundred thousand records and hundred
thousand queries and again here a four
or five runs of this and again here the
the number plus the run time is a lot
lower for this partially because we're
having a lot fewer queries this is a one
fifth number of queries and since we're
maintain and distribution of all the
queries this is much lower runtime our
accuracy is a little worse but still
still pretty reasonable just wrapping up
really quickly I presented a way to give
more practical query release so the main
goal is to kind of handle higher
dimensional data and we want to use
standard solvers on the hard step and it
seems to perform well in practice that
we really have to run more experiments
to really know if we've just gotten
lucky so far or not and some ongoing
future work there's we can try different
solvers as well and I'm also interested
to see how this might scale with a
number of attributes whether we can go
to 2,000 or 5,000 or 20,000 maybe other
classes of queries are possible this
will change the optimization problem but
should in principle be able we can
should go to do this also and yes so
there might be cases when the
optimization problem is easy for certain
classes of queries that we have a
founder yet and there may be other
heuristics for privacy that we have not
considered yet and that's all thanks
what would be your dream kind of data
what what what what properties of those
data so for accuracy we really want to
have a lot of records of course kind of
because the sensitivity depends number
of records right so to kind of
demonstrate how well its approach works
we kind of want data with a lot of
attributes so that's one thing that
we've been struggling with because
there's many there's much real-world
data with a kind of
a lot of attributes but they're usually
not binary so they're kind of continuous
so we can do something like we can
bucket the discrete attributes but then
there's a question about how we can
discretize these things to kind of
really give a fair comparison so we're
kind of looking for data which has a lot
of really independent attributes and
hopefully binary that'd be the best a
lot so at least 2000 attributes we can
handle two thousand random data so
thousands maybe even more yes so my desk
is there to solving this optimization
problem exactly is there a place to for
either approximation so for rotations of
confirmation from worry yeah so there
definitely is the way I described it you
had to find an exact optimum but that's
actually not necessary if you just find
an approximate Ottomans good enough so
like a tool like cplex you can get some
kind of guarantee about how good your
current solution is there's like a
duality gap but because these problems
are hard you may never close at the old
a gap so I may just say there's a gap
that we we may improve by this much but
i'll just take forever to kind of
actually say no we actually don't
approve by that much so it's hard to say
exactly what approximation we're getting
but that's definitely possible as well
okay
so you mentioned that the algorithm you
had its epsilon delta private but you
get this one over cube root of n type
conversions yep is that right is it
clear that this framework would not give
you something more like one of the
squares and um no that's not clear to me
I'm not sure that'd be a regular
mufflers would give you something more
like Marber square root of n yes I think
it's the sampling step so we're kind of
sampling the queries that we're playing
guests so it's a little bit different so
the privacy laws comes not from adding
applause noise but from sampling the
queries from the distribution need to
check
so if you use the Gaussian noise in
projection as a subroutine in boosting
then you do get 1 over root n type sorry
if you use a Gaussian noise plus
projection onto the polytope as a
subroutine for every jaron instead of
and actually get on over 10 tech
dependence right in Fitbit against I
mean these so wait sorry what okay so
here's a listing you can get below 210
if you just replace the subroutines by
something it's like you do oh yeah I
mean opposite another I guess boosting
still has the advantage that you could
use the same thing in our an additional
business again the space complexity is
one the conceptual and it'll be with
this thing is you're actually producing
like this at every point it's not just a
single element and the optimization step
to create a good synthetic data set is
not data independent again by doing this
is that the optimization stuff is
independent of the primitive right right